1984 john ce lieu devient le chef du
parti libéral du canada et premier
ministre consacrer corps et âme à la
tâche de continuer à bâtir une meilleure
canada c'est le summum de sa carrière
politique
mais la descente sera rapide son mandat
durera à peine deux mois et demi john
turner est né en angleterre en 1929 et
des ménages au canada peu après la mort
de son père en 1932 jeunes c'est un
champion canadien d'athlétisme
il se qualifie même pour les jeux
olympiques mais une blessure l'empêchent
d'y participer
après être reçu au barreau il fait chaud
en politique en 1962 et devient
rapidement l'une des vedettes montantes
du parti libéral du canada
celui que l'on qualifie de golden boy et
charmeur populaire en 1968 il tente de
succéder à l'escp eap personne mais est
défait par pierre trudeau qui lui confie
cependant d'importantes responsabilités
il est ministre de la justice lors de
l'adoption de la loi sur les langues
officielles et pendant la crise
d'octobre
il devient ensuite ministre des finances
mais démissionne en 1975
mal à l'aise avec certaines politique
économique du premier ministre
il est aussi à la croisée des chemins de
ses ambitions politiques
effects avait mérité
lorsque au bout du compte il retourne à
ottawa en 1984 il souhaite renouveler un
parti libéral marqué par l'usure du
pouvoir
mais son flair politique et disparus sa
campagne est désorganisée ses bourdes se
succèdent comme ce geste déplacé envers
la présidente du parti lors des débats
il est écrasé par brian mulroney qui lui
reprochent les nominations partisanes
des libéraux le 4 septembre 1984 les
libéraux subissent une véritable raclée
n'obtenant que 40 sièges
loin derrière les conservateurs de brian
mulroney qui font élire deux sens aux
députés nous avons été massacrés en
appellation canadien john turner tente
de rebâtir le parti mais la bisbille
s'installe alimenté par ses relations
tendues avec jean chrétien son rival de
la dernière course à la direction qui
deviendra éventuellement son successeur
1988 nouvelles élections
nouvel affrontement avec brian mulroney
le chef libéral mène une croisade contre
l'accord de libre échange avec les états
unis de faire nos propres choix de notre
propre manière dont n'a pas trouvé
meilleure qu'en payant dépendance mais
il essuie de nouveau la défaite
deux ans plus tard en 1990 il tire sa
révérence en plein tourment du lac meech
il fait un dernier pied de nez à jean
quétier et pierre trudeau meurtri de
l'atalante à presque 15 ans plus tard
paul martin fait appel à lui pour
diriger la délégation canadienne qui
surveille les élections en ukraine est
resté associé aux libéraux toute sa vie
politicien ambitieux mais souvent mal
habile on se souviendra de john turner
pour ces années difficiles à la tête
d'un parti qui le ramenait à deux
défaites électorales
ici daniel thibault radio canada ottawa